I shared some fun facts about Sara before the break,
and now it's time to reveal which one are drew
and which one are false, in our game we call, drew or false.
Okay, let's see the facts again.
A, Sara has a tattoo of the infamous Connors' couch.
B, Sara has three cats, all named Tony
or C, Sara's first girl kiss
was with little old me.
Okay, Sara, which one is true?
All right, the true one is C,
my first girl kiss was with Drew.
(audience applauding)
And I'm not one to kiss and tell, but-
Please do.
But I have to say like, now I'm like gonna blush.
Yes!
Drew was the coolest person that I ever met and,
yeah, and that's what happened.
Well, we were supposed to kiss in the movie
but then we started practicing in the trailer
which was kind of fun.
We had to practice, right?
It was really just us doing research.
Exactly, we were like, oh, I guess we should like practice
because we want it to look good on screen.
(Sara laughing)
(audience laughing)
We had so much fun.
I remember it, I feel like it was in the parking lot
in Los Feliz, right?
We like had that little base camp.
Oh, yeah.
I drove that Jeep and I used to go get
like ice cream on the lunch breaks.
And I was like constantly getting into accidents.
I think I had my license taken away on that movie.
I remember you like dancing
on the hood of the Jeep and, yeah, you were a wild child
but in the best possible way, I was impressed
Well-
And still am.
I am still so impressed with you.
In fact, I was like, oh, I mean,
I loved and watched you on The Talk for so many years.
I was curious of like any words of wisdom, you know,
like any thoughts for me and my new job?
Oh, you're doing such an amazing job.
I mean, I think it's a perfect job for you
because the people who do the best at it are authentic
and you are, so you, you couldn't really be any other way.
And you're so human and caring and it's just ideal.
Are you loving it?
I really, I love it a lot.
I love it so much.
Yeah, and are you able to find time to act
and do other things you love or has it been
all (indistinct)?
No.
No, it's the kids, you know,
the kids are on the front burner and in fact
I stopped doing movies for a while
because I wanted to raise them and be a present mom.
And then the further I got away from that
the more I had a harder time connecting with it.
And I thought I've gotta find the pretty little middle,
I want to work and I wanna be there for my kids.
And then this job is as hard as it is, it's good for both.
And you know, how do you like try to balance it all
with everything you're doing and your kids?
I think, I just take it day-to-day
and look at where there's time and try to make sure that,
you know, when five or five o'clock or dinner comes,
that no matter how busy the day is,
there's that connecting time towards the end of the day.
But it's for sure always a balance
and some days are better than others.
And like Carley to bring it full-circle,
you know, think outside of yourself as much as we're all
drowning within and around that this 17-year-old
is out there taking care of helpless creatures
and what an inspiration for us as humans,
as parents and everything else.
Yeah, and it does make you feel so much better
when you're able to give and give back and do for others.
You know, it does a lot for your own mental wellbeing.
Yeah, and seeing people do good things,
Sara,
you are just the best girl kiss a girl
could ever ask for, and I miss you dearly.
Me too, same on all of the above.
The Conners airs Wednesday on ABC.
(upbeat music)